this video and solo podcast episode
is on the long-term future possibilities
of brain computer interfaces and
neural link specifically based on
the recent update of progress given by
the neural link team i have a basic
outline in front of me with some ideas
but
most of it is just off the top of my
head so i hope you're okay listening to
that kind of thing about my general
thoughts
about neurolink and the recent update of
progress
i was fortunate enough to attend the
demo in person
as a random visitor really and
chat with another random but much
much smarter visitor jim keller
with whom uh i did a podcast a while ago
and we agreed to do another
with him soon he's one of the most
interesting and brilliant people i know
so it was great to catch up but outside
of that i was just a spectator
like everybody else watching online i
have no
insider information have no interest in
insider information
i'm just a fan long time fan of the
human brain
and anyone who's working hard to
understand
its inner workings the general sense i
got
is that there's a lot of exciting
engineering and scientific challenges
that the big and varied team there is
tackling
i think it's a really exciting place to
be just lots of ideas swimming in the
air
and lots of brilliant people it's always
exciting to me
to sort of be in the presence of great
engineering teams so it's exciting to
see that
but what i found especially exciting for
my
romantic and scientific soul
is the long-term vision the dreams
the possibilities that were mentioned by
the team on a
spontaneous final question that was
asked where
every member of the team up there
answered
their own version of what they're
excited about to see
in the next decade two decades long-term
future possibilities of technology so
this video is about that
my thoughts about the possible ways that
neurolink
might change the world and the human
condition
i'll try to stick to some categories
some structure
and try to discuss off the top of my
head my thoughts of the possibilities
that fall within those categories
i should note here that a lot of the
things i'll discuss
are long-term visions of the future to
make all of these visions of reality is
exceptionally difficult
there's a journey of many breakthroughs
required
but i think we are now in the realm
where a lot of these things
are scientific and engineering
challenges that can be solved by
great teams by bold innovation from
many companies not just neural link
hopefully many others hopefully many
competitors
that push the boundaries of what is
possible but
this video is about the visions
of the possible futures and i think
great efforts of humankind start with a
vision
let me give you a quick outline of
categories within
which i see some exciting possibilities
so first is alleviation of human
suffering
second is understanding of consciousness
intelligence
third is augmentation of the body and
mind
and generally augmenting reality fourth
is gaming and beyond that
virtual world virtual reality fifth is
all the engineering challenges around
merging
biological systems and computational
systems basically tech
sixth is telepathy much richer forms of
different communication
seventh is saving and replaying of
memories
but also saving and replaying of mental
state or mind states
period and finally eighth is merging
with artificial intelligence
all the exciting possibilities around
that that i'd like to discuss
so since i'm russian let's start by
discussing human suffering
i think first and foremost as was
mentioned by the team is the possibility
that neurolink might help alleviate
human suffering
the nervous system the brain at the very
basic level is the source of pain
that's both physical pain and
psychological pain so you can talk about
anxiety depression trauma of all
different kinds
the ability to measure signals from the
brain and perhaps more importantly
the ability to send signals and in a
closed loop
interact continuously with the brain
sending signals
in both directions it seems like it
provides a very rich
tool kit with which to start to deeply
understand
the human brain generally but in the
nearest term
to focus that exploration on the
understanding of
neurological diseases so that we may
first of course
understand and second to treat them
a huge number of mysteries yet to be
uncovered at the very basic level
of how do we treat some of these
diseases and that falls into the
category of human suffering
you know we often think about suffering
as arising from the
environment within which the individual
lives
so by placing the focus on the
environment it allows us to kind of
be hopeful because we can make the
environment better
the source of trauma the source of
anxiety the source of depression
all of the things that come up in
political discourse these are all things
that we can do something about
so that's what we focus on when we try
to alleviate human suffering
but from another perspective the real
source
of suffering and pain
is the human mind which creates the
experience the lived experience
from the perception of the external
environment and the perception of the
internal environment
now there's a lot of discussion of
meditation
exercise a lot of
social programs and education all kinds
of things
that aim to help the mind
but in addition to that the exciting
possibility with a brain computer
interface is that
we might be able to accelerate our
understanding
and treatment and control
of the internal environment of the mind
now of course it's also important to say
that there's injustice in the world
there's evil in the world neither
neurolink or any other piece of
technology will be able to get rid of
hatred in the world but
the hope is that at the individual level
you'll be able to aid
in the alleviation to some degree
of all the sources of neurological
suffering
so second category of future
possibilities in your link
have to do around our understanding of
how the brain
and the mind works and all of the things
that derive from that
so basically we'll supercharge research
going on in
neuroscience today so first is
understanding how the brain works
at the functional level so all the
different modules
from memory to perception to cognition
and all the sub-modules of that and
as we untangle those pieces it's
possible
that it will inspire or instruct
us on the engineering side of how to
build smarter and smarter
artificial intelligence systems so
inspire totally new algorithms for
learning systems for reasoning systems
for knowledge base
knowledge acquisition and so on and as
you push that further
of course to me as a artificial
intelligence researcher
the exciting possibility is that we may
be able to understand
human intelligence where not
location wise but functionally where
intelligence
arises in the brain or good answers to
the question of what is
intelligence and the next step
is beyond just engineering ai systems
that may help us understand how we
enhance it
you have all these productivity hacks
all these kind of life hacks
understanding from where our ability to
reason
about this world comes from
might help us to really have some nice
brain hacks
to improve our ability to reason in a
purely natural way
i'm referring to this is before any kind
of augmentation
from a computational device not the next
level of understanding the human brain
as was mentioned by the team as i bring
up often
the fascinating hardest most interesting
problem i would say of the mind
is the hard problem of consciousness
beyond
intelligence we're does consciousness
arise from the brain again
not location wise but functionally and
again to be able to with more
scientific rigor answer the question
what is consciousness
is it a property of matter is it a
unique
emergent property of the human brain is
it something totally different that we
don't even understand
like our mind is some kind of key into
an alternate dimension
that uh only psychedelics
and uh a device like neurolink may be
able to unlock
so at the risk of sounding crazy it's an
exciting possibility to take
consciousness from
i would say i feel of philosophy in the
20th century
to a field of science and engineering in
a 21st century
to me that's deeply interlinked with
intelligence because i think there's a
beautiful dance there between
consciousness and intelligence and the
human mind
that's not easy or even necessary to
untangle
but i think understanding one will help
us understand the other
and finally perhaps interconnected with
consciousness
and intelligence it might help us take
the question of is there free will
into the realm of science and
engineering versus
the realm of philosophy to try to make a
rigorous study of
where does this experience of
making a choice making decisions like
we humans have a control of the way the
future unfolds
from where that arises is that a real
part of the fabric of reality or is that
something that the brain conjures up
what i see neurolink as as i talked with
elon the second time on the podcast
i see it as a way to sort of get beyond
the
the factory walls and see how the inner
workings of the
factories operate as a scientist as an
engineer
and a bit of a philosopher
that's truly exciting third future
possibility of neurolink
is augmentations of all different kinds
so regaining the ability to move
for people who can't move parts of their
body i mentioned
neurological conditions that affect the
mind but certainly there's neurological
conditions that affect
the body i mean giving people
who can't walk the ability to walk again
or to walk for the first time such an
exciting possibility
if you've seen uh videos of
people who for the first time are able
to see color
or gain a function that they didn't have
before
through technology the bliss in their
eyes
is uh is magical now the augmentation
doesn't have to be just in regaining the
physical function
of the body it could be augmentation to
the mind
it could be for example regaining the
ability to see
by stimulating the visual cortex
connecting a camera to the visual cortex
and perhaps more than regaining regular
visual function
it could lead to superhuman level vision
whether that's expanding the spectrum
like ability to see infrared or it's
doing some
basic augmented reality kind of things
where
some of the detections are done for you
about moving objects about the
categories of objects and all that kind
of stuff
many of the ideas here are the same as
those explored by
the work that people are doing in
augmented reality devices
but it's it's very possible that the
difference between
a brain computer interface and glasses
for example or
heads-up displays is that bcis
might be able to create a much richer
high bandwidth
experience with a fast closed loop
of perception more so than the
constraints that you have to operate
under with glasses or
huds fourth a super exciting possibility
for those of us who were once gamers
or still are gamers is
by creating an immersive gaming
experience so
bcis might be able to once again read
the brain and stimulate parts of the
brain
that enrich in some way the the gaming
experience
this could be very shallow kind of basic
enrichment
just being able to measure levels of
excitement
emotion those kinds of things that can
aid in the experience
of the game but also again as i said
with augmented reality
being able to stimulate the visual
cortex in order to create an immersive
visual experience so with a brain
computer interface
beyond just gaming you can start to
think about creating virtual worlds
virtual reality that's very useful for
games but
just creating an immersive experience of
all different kinds
again this is an open question but there
could be
technical barriers in creating an
immersive rich
high bandwidth experience with a virtual
reality headset
versus a brain computer interface it's
an open
question of creating a fully immersive
experience
what is easier to do in the long sort of
arc of history
with the technology we have today it
seems clearly more doable in the short
term
to create virtual reality experiences
with a headset
as opposed to something that requires
brain surgery but that's not to say if
we look at the
long arc of technological progress that
the much easier solution won't come
from the direct access to the brain
through something like a brain computer
interface
and again i think bigger than gaming a
lot of people write to me about
psychedelics for example which i've
never done
but this would be an example of
something where you can create
visual experiences that are
safe and controlled and can take you
perhaps to some of those different
multiple dimensions
or wherever the heck you go when you
take psychedelics
in a more controlled way perhaps
and maybe even taking a step back into
more kind of vanilla experiences of
visualizations and meditation
so imagine the closed loop
of being able to write and read from the
brain
in aiding the meditation experience
sort of emptying your
brain from thoughts figuratively
and literally the fifth exciting future
possibilities
of neuralink and brain computer
interfaces
is all the innovation engineering around
the two-way communication between a
human-made
electrical computational system and a
biological system
just the the fabric the nature of the
two
design paradigms not saying biological
systems are designed
but they are designed through evolution
whatever that resilient
mess mush of biology to the more
structured
architectured electrical systems that
are programmed
explicitly and clearly the communication
between these two different worlds
and bringing them closer and closer
together is super exciting
first at the very basic level there
could be all the innovation around
robotic neurosurgery or even surgery in
general
so allowing robots to do what narrow ai
systems do best
which is for basic tasks that have
vision and control where everything's
controlled in the environment fully
actuated system
to be able to minimize the risk of
injury
maximize the probability of success so
there's a lot of interesting innovations
around just the robotic side of that the
next layer of that when you look at some
of the
materials engineering and even the
computational
side of connecting the laces to the
brain so connecting
the electrical device to the biological
device
we may be able to understand how to
engineer sort of physical computational
systems
that have some of the same nice
properties of resilience
that biological systems have and in so
doing be able to work better with
biological systems
but also just be able to be more
resilient more robust
more adaptable perhaps or maybe come up
with totally different ways that such
systems can learn about their
environment
just like our biological systems can at
multiple levels
and another layer of that when you look
at what
neurolink is currently doing they have
1024 channels
the engineering around scaling that
to i don't want to put numbers out but
any number above that is super exciting
it's already
100x anything else that's out there but
you can imagine
especially long term it being ten
thousand hundred thousand
i mean it could be millions maybe
billions i mean there's so much
possibility of
engineering breakthroughs about the
number of channels
that are possible that we can't yet
imagine and that's a engineering
challenge of how to scale these
number of connections which are tricky
to do because they have to
live exist successfully in cooperation
with biological systems for
months years you know for long periods
of time
that's really interesting i feel like
that's a forcing function
for us to understand really how we can
engineer systems that
in the best possible ways are
not only able to uh work with other
biological systems but become more
like those biological systems so
sixth possible future of neurolink and
bcis
was mentioned a few times by the team
under the flag of telepathic
communication or telepathy
conceptual and consensual telepathy
so i think in general to
enrich the the bandwidth
in quantity and quality of the
communication between two human beings
so you can imagine being able to
communicate
not just through this kind of 1d
realm of words but to communicate visual
concepts first of all
but also kind of mind maps of like
multi-dimensional concept maps that are
in our mind when we're trying to
reason through things to be able to
communicate
those in some way it doesn't even have
to be kind of a
perfect replication but any kind of
improvement increase in the bandwidth of
the communication between humans
on the visual or on the conceptual side
is super interesting i think somebody on
the team mentioned kind of
art to be able to communicate creative
artistic kind of things in your mind and
share them with others
without having to learn the skill of
converting that
art into uh something in the physical
world that's
uh that can be you know observed by
others you can sort of directly without
learning the skill be able to
communicate all the crazy beautiful
things that are in your mind
i think for my world of like programming
for example
it'd be exciting to think that two human
beings
at any level could sort of collaborate
together uh
it gives a whole nother meaning to pear
coding where two people can
collaborate together as they work in a
on a project of any kind whether it's in
the programming world or any kind of
design world
architecture any kind of illustrations
all that kind of stuff collaborations
between humans
for uh intellectual labor for
design for engineering work or any any
kind of collaboration
in the intellectual space and uh finally
i think it'd be pretty good for
podcasting
so uh for those of us who don't like the
sound of our voice
and funny enough don't like to be in
front of the camera
instead of having to convert my thoughts
awkwardly in a monotone voice
into a microphone i can somehow
communicate them in a much richer way
which
i think at least for an introvert i
think the kind of things going on in my
mind
seem to be much more eloquent and
interesting
than the kind of things that come out of
my mouth when i perform the conversion
so from like a car mechanic or maybe i
should say
like brain mechanic perspective my
uh converter it's not working very well
between the
the brain thoughts and visualizations
and concepts based to
mouth speaking different uh
english concepts so i look forward to uh
this podcast
being consumed and generated
telepathically
so seven possible future application of
neurolink
would be the ability to save and replay
memories
or save and replay mind states it's a
way to do what
daniel kahneman for example talks about
as many of us kind of
live life through memories
of previous events so kind of the
memorable
special things that happen to us are
experienced
more deeply and more frequently through
our memories
than directly when we actually
experience them for the first time
and the exciting possibility of neural
link is
basically improving the resolution
of that memory replay that we generally
do anyway
as people should check out daniel
kahneman's work he
describes it quite eloquently and it's
true many of us
live in our memories it's also from a
certain perspective uh
nice to be able to modify delete
or alter some of those memories so for
example
on a on a darker side it could be
traumatic events
that you know from a psychological
perspective could be haunting
you can remove or at least alleviate the
impact
of those memories onto your cognition
or maybe pull stuff from the
subconscious you can think of it as a
freud's favorite kind of toolkit to uh
play around and explore with our own
mind
to uh discover our demons so as opposed
to the david goggins approach
that i've taken recently of doing insane
amounts of exercise
to uh to discover and have a
conversation with my demons
could do it in a more controlled and
safe environment
of uh brain computer interfaces as a
quick side note there's interesting
echoes
of uh the memory replay that you've seen
our reinforcement learning systems so
it's kind of interesting to think that
instead of just us being able to replay
our memories
it could be our own little machine
learning systems that can
learn something from our previous
memories by replaying them over and over
to try to give us maybe a strategy of
how to avoid those memories in the past
so it's basically converting our prior
experiences into data
and once it's converted into data that
could be used
for all kinds of applications so you can
think of like a personal machine
learning system that can
replay your memories and uh try to
figure out try to be a
a personal executive assistant to you to
advise you what to learn from those
experiences
with a lot of these applications that
i've already discussed
privacy and security is of paramount
importance i mean like with actually
a lot of our technology but this is very
much at the forefront
of what uh neurolink is working on
currently
and always will be and i think a lot of
companies
in general in the tech space will sink
or swim
based on how much they respect privacy
and security
i think in the early days of our
development with social networks and so
on
you could get away easier by being
careless with people's data
i think my long-term perhaps optimistic
but i think
it's a realistic view of the future that
people will demand
much more control over their data
demand much more transparency around
privacy and security
transparency and clarity so of course
that's underlying all the different
features that i'm uh discussing and
finally to move a little bit beyond
the ability to save and replay memories
is to save mental states
and that's essentially a path towards
digital immortality
so you can think of being able to save
the contents
or the critical contents of your mind
into
digital form and then being able to
transfer to other systems
to robots or as in for example my
discussion with sarah seeger who
searches for habitable planets outside
our solar system
exoplanets we discussed the idea that
one way perhaps to reach far away
livable planets that might have
extraterrestrial intelligent life on
them
is by sending digital humans there
so being able to save essential or
entire contents of the human mind and to
be able to
reload it once you arrive into uh any
kind of whether it's a biological
or a robotic system so that's that's the
kind of stuff that
ray kurzweil thinks about it's also a
i think a lot of people are excited
about
is the ability to store
and digitally transfer the contents
the important the beautiful contents of
the human mind
finally the eighth future possibility of
neurolink and also one of the original
motivations
behind the company is the methodology
by which the human mind
the human brain the
human society can merge
with artificial intelligence systems
once they're able to achieve
human level and superhuman level
intelligence since
the origins of the field of ai most
if not all of the progress that's been
made has been
in what might be called narrow
artificial intelligence
but as a lot of people have discussed
now there's a lot of debates around this
there's a lot of thoughts
but but it seems very possible that
humans limited though we are will one
day be able to
engineer systems that are far more
intelligent than us human beings
in some dimension that fundamentally
changes the fabric
of human society so we already have ai
systems that are much better
at a lot of things in humans in a narrow
way
but there might be a set of dimensions
where an intelligent system is able to
generalize better than humans in a set
of tasks
that can lead to existential risks to
human beings
where artificial intelligence systems
essentially become a kind of
direct or indirect competitor whether
that's a paper clip manufacturing ai
systems that
destroys all humans just to make its
manufacture paper clips a little bit
more efficient
or if it's a much more complex
distributed
system kind of like our social networks
of today but much smarter
with some kind of combination of gpt 3
or gpt-20 systems that kind of creep
up on us like the boiling water creeps
up on the lobster
and overwhelms the resources or the
capacities of human civilization
in a way that's fundamentally traumatic
or destructive or
poses an existential risk even if that
point is far away in time
and that's difficult to predict i think
it's
very difficult to rationally say
that we will never reach that point
so once you allow that as a possibility
you start to think from a
engineering perspective how can we
minimize the existential risk associated
with that
and then creating ways to merge with the
ai
so we kind of ride the wave of ai and
they ride the wave of the
functionalities of the human brain
is an interesting possibility i think
it's a
beautiful vision of a future that's
mostly
filled with mystery so we don't know how
agi systems will evolve
but it's an interesting idea that
as ai systems become smarter and smarter
it is one way to ensure our survival
is to expand the capacity of the human
mind to communicate with ai
and with the ai to communicate with the
human mind at the
basic level to me that's super exciting
because
ai systems can learn from the brain the
brain can learn from ai systems
and i'm as a person who is a big fan of
deep thinking of
sitting for multiple hours and focusing
on a single idea
and just thinking with a sheet of paper
and thinking about an idea
i find myself needing to look up things
a lot and that's actually a huge
distraction and it's a huge
drain on my mental resources
and and the kind of distraction the the
timing of the
thinking is disrupted by having to look
up
different kinds of information to look
up different kinds of papers
to look up even basic information on
wikipedia
so the ability to kind of close the loop
to increase the bandwidth
of thinking of the lookup of the
information that's available
online is super exciting to me now
that's not
even agi that's just like basic uh
recommender systems basic search engines
basic even like gbt three
plus plus type of communication back and
forth
i think that's really exciting to
empower the brain
as it's doing the usual kind of deep
thinking that it's capable
of and then of course
but then of course you could take that
farther as the ai systems get smarter
and smarter and smarter
if we completely open the gates of the
communication
in two ways then it increases the
likelihood of agi not leaving us behind
and i think that's a scary and exciting
future
and that's probably where we humans do
our best work
i hope these thoughts were interesting
useful to some of you
in these difficult times of economic
pain
of political division i personally
and i hope others do too draw a lot of
inspiration from
companies from people from scientists
that are boldly pushing forward the
limits of human knowledge
the limits of human capability and just
engineering and building
doing their best to engineer and build a
better future
for our world so i hope you find it
inspiring as well and as always i love
you all
and hope to see you next time
you